an all too familiar sight in Ukraine's
Capital Kiev according to the Ukrainian
Air Force 81 missiles were fired in the
early hours of Thursday morning
including six Hypersonic missiles which
can travel up to eight kilometers a
second Ukraine said it intercepted 34
cruise missiles but doesn't have the
ability to intercept the Hypersonic
missiles 40 of Kiev is now without power
very loud explosion very loud we quickly
jumped out of bed and saw one car on
fire then there are other cars caught on
fire as well the glass shattered on the
balconies and windows it's very
frightening the child got scared and
jumped out of bed Rescue Services have
become accustomed to dealing with the
aftermath of airstrikes
I woke up from the explosion but quite a
strong one but I could never imagine
that it would happen in my backyard when
I went outside I realized those cars are
in the yard it is hard to explain how I
feel because one meter left or right and
it could have been my apartment I have
no words left
in the west four people were killed when
missiles hit solicit
ukrainians say residential buildings
were destroyed in the attack
elsewhere in the East the battle for
bakmut is intensifying with the Russians
saying they now control the east of the
besieged city
Ukrainian military though still hanging
on for now
the team of the tank has fire from the
concealed position at the enemy
positions the target is hit boys are
good we've sent our greetings to the
uninvited guests that came to our
country bakmud is standing we will win
the attention continues to be in the
East with the heaviest fighting is
taking place
but Russia has reminded Ukraine with
this latest set of attacks it has the
ability to strike anywhere Al Jazeera